- Mila was here a few months ago
and talked about the first time
that Ashton said he loved her
and I think it's incredible.
So, I wanna show you.
(Ashton chuckles)
(graphics whooshing)
- It happened to me and
it happened to my mother.
So,
(Kelly laughs)
my dad told my mom he was in
love with her three months
into their relationship,
shmammered, fully shmammered.
And my mom went, "All right,
talk to me in the morning."
Like, "We'll reconvene this."
- Yeah.
- Same thing happened
to me with my husband.
Three months into our relationship,
he like showed up in my house
at two o'clock in the morning
and he was like, "I love you so much."
(crowd laughing)
And I was like,
"Oh, Lord, have-"
I was like, "Go to bed."
And he goes, "No, I love you so much."
And I was like,
"Okay, if you remember-"
- Super great, go home.
(crowd clapping)
So-
- Okay.
- Yeah, what's happening?
- What do you remember about the night?
- Oh, I remember it.
I'll give details.
- Okay.
- I remember it distinctly
'cause I came into her house
and I was singing this Kenny Chesney song
and I was like-
♪ You and tequila make me crazy ♪
'Cause there had been a little
too much tequila consumed
and they both make me crazy.
And then I told her that I love her
and I meant it when I said it.
And she was like, "Just tell
me, say that in the morning."
And then before I woke
her up and I was like,
"Hey, I love you."
- Aww.
- And that's how I woke
her up in the morning.
I remember, distinctly.
I don't know how I remember
'cause I was really drunk, but-
- Sometimes, though, it is,
it takes a little liquid courage
to let the old walls down.
- It's a little juice.
- Yeah.
- Get a little juice.